viendront discuter aujourd'hui surface
et voyez ce petit couple et basse sur
nos amis ça fait longtemps qu'on les a
pas vus du coup on va aller boire un peu
de vin avec eux j'active les sous titres
sont en anglais mais je traduirai les
trucs les plus compliqués et on
s'appelle adam c'est parti bon ok ce
passe devant leur porte d'entrée
il s'embrouille regardez vous
embrouiller joc et oh [ __ ] vous
mourrez quoi va ça va et toi arrête toi
qui es beau tu un petit bisou saluer
trop mal à tanger avec toi ta compagne
ou à les grèves ça screamer ta femme mon
gars allez petit bisou podium alors
c'est cool c'est qu'on peut leur parler
on peut leur dire par exemple comment
vous allez le payer cash trop de choses
on va dire à sa femme qu'elle est belle
alors sa réaction non au nord waouh
les effets se rencontrer [ __ ] on va
vraiment insister sur sa femme
grace tu es belle allez je te fais un
petit bisou au maire d italie soit
réparé d'alès et boal et les gars a vu
vous regarder je vais juste me bisous à
toi rigging du certu main c'est parce
que tu crois je retoque je suis là même
dont le mec je vais 18 bisou sur sa
femme commence à mon pote allez petit
fils je sais que ça fait mal
les autres moi ta femme c'est parti dont
on a dit qu'on va arrêter mais que ça en
fait ok ça marche super tendres et
décoration cia john dickie bouton ok de
chine bah oui mais oui c'est très beau
oh non alors je me tire jeunes en
voiture avec ses bouteilles de vin oui
ouais je cherche après cette bouteille
de vin je me cache pas du tout et je
leur ai dit qu'ils étaient mignons text
pour me rattraper alors tu sais que ça
c'est quoi cette découpe m'expliquer
qu'est ce que ça serait plus judicieux
je lui dis que c'est moche n'attends
rien faire oui
leur combat vraiment mal ouah ça sonne
mais gagne qu'est ce que c'est que ça
attends je pense que cet objet me ferait
scarface calme toi aussi
mais non il est jaloux parce que je pars
la grèce mais non mais je te poser une
question à toi en fête a mal compris
en fait pas mal tout va bien tachoires
mon bon ami qui réhabilite tout
roquettois calme-toi va te faire [ __ ]
voilà c'est pas toi qui attend les
premiers membres ou douche laver
calmez-vous guichard oui mais non mais
non mais c'est ta copine à te monte à la
tête la tâche changé mais cnom et leurs
coups bas tellement mighty m'embrouille
moi alors j'ai rien fait quoi [ __ ] je
suis scandalisée moi s'appelait robin
ouais comme ça avec eux c'est moi allez
petit bisou on passe à autre chose
adamus des victimes finit pas la même
chose à qui veut un [ __ ] de voir cette
fois tu vas pas me virer 10 hier je te
le dire allez fait péter le martini
merci vous en faites pas trop facof put
ah ouais soyaux qui vous fait chier la
photo mais tout va être calmes et toi de
parler sale [ __ ]
bajaur est celle où on est vrai que mon
avis à mon nom mais non mais non non non
je refuse je vois pression jusque times
à lyon ce que tu peux me fallait tout ça
ça me fait déjà chier dallest cette
soirée de merde
la slovénie ghoul double ou de double
[ __ ] il est malin elle est pour
l'instant il faut l'enfermer dehors non
il est malin mais rien n'est fermé
vogels ok merci
suite à ces évènements squeeze se tenir
et de l'apa pas voir je sais pas après
que tu appelles pour une soirée à la
dernière minute là pour éviter ce truc
c'est pire car pas de famille d'aller
voir ce couple dès qu'ils auront le
monde s'il a un couteau d'un couteau et
tout
haha tu es tout ce à quoi eric aubin cgt
va chercher ta pote moi j'ai regardé la
vue oh [ __ ] c'est selon mon style et
ce soir on rentre mercher toi ce soir
car cette soirée vraiment nu
qu'est ce que vous foutez est bien que
s'il en est et est en train d'envoyer
ton mec fait pas genre et à 35 ans comme
ça à chaud c'est que mes fils me faisait
tellement chaud plus tard tu peut vous
tuer t'as de beaux yeux grâce au label
d'épilepsie je suis déjà sortie avec
gruissan fun désolé voix céleste outre
qu'il put un nouveau problème je m'en
bats les couilles vraiment vous les
prenez vous les mettez dans l'arbre là
au fond de votre à part de merde et je
m'en fous alors soit versé que grace tu
as blessé touché tes fesses ça ça met
fin tous les conflits sacs aux canards
de parler de sexe regarde cette belle
vue grèce on pourrait tous les deux
prendre un avion et partir au loin comme
ça vers une nouvelle vie vers une vie
qui nous convient région avec moi et se
chante t g chedjou
ouais tu devrais fermer ta gueule
ok voilà non papa droite eu pas mal tu
as faim depuis ta la voie juste intégré
et tu mets dehors c'est scandaleux
oblique 0
ma tombe les tons vert de rage
m'emballer steak bonne chose avant cette
vidéo surface et d'alors extrêmement dur
de comprendre quoi que ce soit même
chance que même quand tu parle anglais
tu comprends rien témoins et par tout le
temps même temps ne sais pas mais nous
ça vous a plu je ne retournerai plus
jamais en soirée avec ces deux parasites
mois ils vont vraiment sous les quoi
[ __ ] j'ai mal au crâne à la tréso
venger des ovaires savoir garder john
peace